no matter what you hear in this review
the fact remains I really enjoy the
first Pacific Rim movie I enjoyed it so
much I named my dogs after it kind of
eat gypsy and danger maybe you've seen
it before I think they were a little
smaller then man you guys are happy
happy when you look anyway either I feed
you too much or don't walk you enough
which one do you think yeah both Pacific
Rim uprising sofa cific rim uprising is
the sequel to Pacific Rim Pacific Rim
directed by Guillermo del Toro robots
vs. monsters pretty much what you need
to know after they closed the breach at
the end of Pacific Rim line we now have
John boyega who plays the son of
interest Elvis character from the first
Pacific Rim and [ __ ] to hold [ __ ]
dangers not backs now [ __ ] Avengers the
main one no danger I'm not gonna change
her name to Avenger and now new threats
emerging now we have a sequel to Pacific
Rim it's clearly not directed by
Guillermo del Toro producing this by
saying it's gonna be hard to live up to
the first Pacific Rim I feel like the
first Pacific Rim was lightning in a
bottle
I mean some people love it some people
hate it I'm one of the ones who loved it
because Pacific Rim one was very
self-aware it knew what it was big
robots versus big monsters let's have
some vines Oh Pacific Rim one was
elevated because you couldn't tell it
was directed by a very talented hand I
feel like this movie bit off a bit more
than it can do because it tried to
expand its lore too much I get for the
sequel you want to try new things
especially you look at the first Pacific
Rim you're like alright is that rogue
pilot he's the best of the best he's the
only one for the job but he doesn't want
to do it but of course he ends up doing
it then you have the best of the best of
the best who's his rival they don't
really like each other but by the end
they're gonna respect each other it's
pretty much Top Gun with big fighting
robots and monsters it's a cliche
formula because it's been used a hundred
times before because it's worked 100
times before is it for groom uprising I
want to give it credit for stepping out
a new ground expanding its lore going
into new territory for Pacific Rim
that's it an attempt it doesn't make a
success there's a story of a guy who
attempted to fly off of the Eiffel Tower
Rob's for the attempts didn't work out
well for him because he did not live
through it that's kind of the same thing
when john boyega's greatness movie he
elevates any movie he's in you can take
John boyega put him in a crappy movie or
at least take John boyega and put him in
the crappiest mission in a movie and he
will be the one who shines in that
darkness because he is so damn likeable
and talented that's how he is in this
movie he has the microphone for about
90% of his film but it's 75 is still of
the majority
pretty much john boyega's movie starts
getting dragged down because we
concentrate too much on human beings
there's this little girl that comes into
the fold at the very beginning isolation
comes in around the same time john
boyega's character and she's with these
other kids you think it's gonna be this
training thing like maybe Kingsman the
Secret Service baby's gonna be a lot of
training within we see their skills not
really go to scientists or back they
were the ones from the first movie I'm
like you overcooked it a little bit but
did he grow on me in the first film they
do something with Charlie Dee's
character in here it's so stupid it's
like a shittier version of something I
saw in Mass Effect 2 somewhere take that
how you will really if you're looking
for Yeager on kaiju action the kaiju
really don't show up until the last act
of the movie Pacific Rim 1 there was
dead space and they're filled with that
cliche plot I was talking about it at
least ok I don't mean to keep comparing
this to Pacific Rim 1 but anyone who
said you can't compare the second movie
to the first movie is [ __ ] wrong
because it's a sequel you're allowed to
compare it to the first movie so if
you're looking at Pacific Rim 1 it
starts you out with a big fight it ends
you with a big fight you fill in the gap
with their cliches and actually their
character intrigued yeah there's a
little bit of that in there the Idris
Elba's knows you weren't curious for a
little bit it was bleeding but the kaiju
were always a presence because you saw
news clips of them there was a flashback
in there I mean the end fight in this
movie sure I kind of had a not a smile I
have a smirk like the end fight was fine
but there's no jaw-dropping Sain this
movie does represent scale ok sometimes
actually there's a better job than I
thought ever as good as the first movie
but the movies biggest flaw is that it
tries to expand too much it overreaches
it gets convoluted too many irons in the
fire and if for Goblet Pacific Rim was
here it is Pacific Rim uprising is to
Pacific Rim how Independence Day
resurgence is to Independence Day it's
the same [ __ ] and it does dawn on me
maybe I'm holding Pacific Rim 1 to a
higher standard because I have goggles
on those nostalgia goggles just to be
sure I watched the first Pacific Rim
last night happy to say very much
enjoyed it found a lot of enjoyment and
it also found more flaws than I saw when
I first saw it almost half a decade ago
that'll be a case with any movie any
movie you watch you can review half a
decade later you kind of see it
different which a silver lining here
maybe a half a decade from now I will
look back at Pacific Rim uprising and
actually enjoy it but for right now on
this day I'm just not gonna remember
this movie in t-minus a couple of days
yep already forgot if that writing
bothers you I got just the cure
I've seen dangerous thank you for coming
by today right so Pacific Rim uprising
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]